oh they're totally different in every
way the thing that I value most about
fiction is how free it is that anytime
there's something I want to pursue I can
if I become curious about something or
you know something catches my fancy or
seems interesting I just do it I follow
it there's no question about usefulness
or a necessary destination and with
nonfiction I always felt bound both to
reality you know my book had something
like I don't know 80 pages of footnotes
but also to a conversation that I wanted
to have so every morning when I woke up
when I was writing eating animals I knew
what I was going to work on every
morning when I wake up to write fiction
even if I'm at the end of a book I in a
very fundamental way I don't know what
I'm going to work on each subsequent
sentence feels like a mystery or a
possibility anyway so I was grateful to
have that you know certainty of sort of
a line of thought that I was pursuing
but it's also very difficult because I
felt so constrained
well I begin with nothing and I
unfortunately usually end with nothing
in terms of a day-to-day process but
it's just a blank page I've never had
characters before I started writing I've
never had a morel I've never had a story
to tell I've never had some voice that I
found and wanted to share on and the
poet's that I look at what I write so
that I can see what I think and that's
been very true for me and my process
it's I don't I don't have a thought that
I then try to articulate it's only
through the act of writing that I try to
find my own thoughts so it can be quite
scary because you know it's it's there's
a kind of faith I guess that you have to
have either in yourself or in the
process that something good will come
from filling blank pages and it very
very often doesn't feel that way but
every now and then you stumble upon
something some idea which you didn't
know that you'd had or feeling that you
didn't know you'd had and there's
nothing like that revelation and I don't
know if anywhere else in life to find it
Zadie Smith wrote an essay about humour
in The New Yorker and she talked about
the experience of going out with a bunch
of stand-up comedians after a show they
went to a bar and she said they were you
know asking each other was it funny was
it funny was it funny when I held off on
the punchline for that extra second was
it funny when I pointed at that guy in
the audience was it funny when I
delivered that joke with a straight face
and she said you know they're neurotic
and it's crazy and very annoying just
was it funny was it funny but as a
writer she said she felt jealous of them
because at least they knew what the
question was and that's the hardest
thing about writing you don't even know
what good would be you know is a good
book an entertaining one probably not
alone otherwise you know Danielle Steel
might be the greatest author who ever
lived is a good book one that conveys
some kind of moral imagination probably
not is it one that is artful well it's
hard even to know what that means
but they're very very artful books that
very few people can ever get into is it
to be funny is it to be sad is it to be
new is it to be familiar is it to
describe life as people now live it or
is it to do just the opposite
there isn't any one answer but the scary
thing is there might not be any answer
and investing all of your days toward a
question that might not have a good
answer or it might not have an answer
that you ever have access to is very
scary
and that's the hardest thing about
writing